I track lots of stuff and the more ways
you track the more ways you can win if
you track 100 stats then you only need
one of them to go up so you feel like
you made some progress and the second
thing around the tracking is that I
would look at like the biggest possible
number so a lot of times you can see
like the impressions of you know a post
that you make even if you only got like
16 likes I got like a 100 Impressions
and I thought to myself I was like well
if there was a room of 100 people I'd be
stoked like that would be awesome
especially in the early days I would
totally feel like that was worthwhile
and so taking those little impression
numbers and pretending that they were
like micro events that I was making the
work or the content for all of a sudden
made it feel worth it for me